bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fabi j
oggi siamo nuovo horror con l'onlus
trips perché i ragazzi ma ogni volta che
ti costa [ __ ] frase poi il mio cuore
ne risente direi che possiamo iniziare
lasciamo perdere tutto perché voglio che
finisca presto
qualsiasi cosa sia a chi ai ragazzi ci
sia dato non vedo niente a buongiorno
bellissima una parte che sono trova e 66
cuori va beh sì ma perché è giusto
foglio dietro alcun non potevano
metterlo davanti fantastico ragazzi
allora la partenza è buona
mimì mi piace come gioco devo non andrò
mai laden ma neanche morto dai ragazzi
non ha perfezionato ok adesso è meglio
adesso effettivamente ci ha più senso
sta cosa
salve se ti posso andare nome non
c'entrano ormai potendo abbiate pazienza
già mi piace di più ragazzi mi sembra
più allegra si fa per dire ovviamente
solo che non ho figli è la madonna
emesso sono fa vigenti con lennon detto
me ne vado a [ __ ] è normale che tipo
che cazzo si è mosso divano si è mosso
il divano da solo è normale iva se
cambiamo gioco giochiamo a teletubbies
suore meraviglia al cuore trovo a secco
o che hanno trovato uno pur aprendo ok
lo per non so come l'ho preso ma l'ho
preso cazzo me ne faccio non lo so ma
andiamo avanti perchè mi sto calando
addosso grazie è bellissimo quando gioco
sta roba con logo uno strip proprio na
una gioia l'allegria fatta videogioco
sì pronti incazzare un ragazzino lo
sapete che non so neanche dove cazzo sto
andando vero quando sono andata a caso
avanti abbiamo trovato delle novità rega
una porta sono bellissime se porta a
prost a porta ma evitate di farlo non ho
già che lampeggia la torcia mimì mi
girano i [ __ ]
non c'è niente vero possa aprire
vogliono hanno toccato un cazzo è sto
creando addosso fatemi andare avanti di
brutto che i temi che qualcuno ha
mangiato un panino col ketchup tanti
panini col che c'ha lui è sveglio no lei
è sveglia siccome lei è sveglia credo
che sia sangue del ciclo perché sennò
non va beh lasciamo perdere ai fa
incazzare una donna mestruata in questo
periodo soprattutto perché potrebbe
essere terrificanti a dir poco ragazzi
un contratto già al secondo cuore
vediamo anche 14 ragazzi fantastico tra
l'altro lei è sveglia non mi piace sta
scritta questa sarebbe la mappa in
teoria sei tranquillo zio che ciò google
maps faccio prima torniamo indietro che
è meglio tanto ragazzi c'è qualcuno di
sveglio che non [ __ ] ragazzi ok kami
pensavo ci avesse qualcosa di brutto ma
non è successo un cazzo fantastico che
abbiate pazienza ma non mi ricordo una
sega di dover la strada da dove era
arrivato quindi vado a casa finché non
trova cosa chiamare mancano qua la
madonna che è sta roba che duri lo
strano ora non si può ma qua dentro e
sotto tiro due schiaffi non so se
teheran detto ma qui è vietato fumare
lurido quindi evita di di funghi cazzo è
salve si può fumare qua dentro e non è
che un altro cuore fantastico fatemi
prendere il suo schifo
sono meta ragazze ancora non ho visto
ringraziando iddio non ho visto niente
solo chiedevo capitato la sequela tipo è
spuntato un muro a caso cioè non c'era
prima quel muro non voglio neanche
sapere che cazzo c'è sul soffitto e
altre che non si può ma non si può mario
non c'è chi è che mette cambiamo il
joker e gambe e non dire che mette teste
freccia delle palle perché io non è
trovai non c'è neanche più la torcia
misti scassata la torcia affanculo entro
ok ok funziona minchia che ringraziando
indiano la torcia funziona ci sono
talmente tante volte che potrei
sbagliare grazie della freccia è molto
gentile un'altra basta sport io mio
ragazzi cosa da matti le mani e cazzo di
loki ha sporcato i muri io sono
pulitissime zia sito che si sporca di
sangue
dunque un altro cosa 14 io mi chiede
cosa c'è qualcosa c'è la testa di zio
bobby seriamente che cazzo ci fate st
rizzi obi a terra va bene lasciamo
perdere 4 regala prega merda lo sapevo
carnia ok voglio spegnere abbiate
pazienza che
dove ancora si fece di merda un'altra
passaste porte ci fai qui no way out
nessuna via di fuga tua sorella insomma
via di fuga ma qualcosa mi sta dicendo
che devo entrare in quella porta però
non non so perché ci sto presentimento
io non scendo ma invece io ci entra non
è che mi fiderei tanto di indicazioni
fatte col sangue sul muro è però la
massa di porta in porta
sì sì un altro cuore ragazzi l'altro qua
perfetto ok ci siamo ne abbiamo ragazzi
me ne manca uno 1 un [ __ ] cuore che
ciò so presentimento
perché in di chi lo vendo a mezzanotte e
un quarto
[Applauso]
ragazzi una battuta incredibile non vedo
l'ora ok rapezzi quando arrivò alla fine
succede
riprendo un infarto son convinto entro
qua dentro l'ultima porta di nyman e
questa credo
ok perfetto altre frecce che che mi
aiuta ma stazio bobby è rotto il cazzo
cosa non c'è niente qui adesso muori
adesso adesso muoio sentiti o hai
scritto tu sta merda
un'altra [ __ ] sono morto non solo
momento il nostro orto che allora era
una presa per il culo permesso
basta regali dopo questo non ne posso
più ancora ceo bob mai rotto il cazzo
amico mio
si si si assumono un parcheggio è un
ragazzo non ci ho messo qualcosa come
mezz'ora per trovare sostanza cosa dice
che se muovo e colombo meglio allora
prendo sto coso posso aprendo ok sei
sopravvissuto
sì ma chiesa urli territorio sono dovrei
mettermi steso credo tipo così da quando
ragazzi non era poi così male come cosa
solo che sono troppo un figlio ragazze
con creano
non c'erano ma erano i [ __ ] sullo
studio basta è stato orribile non aveva
comunque ho fatto don't look back perché
in teoria c'è anche il 2 di tanto visto
gioco qui non farò più avanti comunque
ragazzi se non perdere parola che mi
sono abbastanza ucciso dalla tensione
quindi ragazzi se il video mi è piaciuto
ma se hai lasciato un commento mi piace
anche la faccia di facebook come noi
video tratta una descrizione se non
dovresti discrete riuscì vediamo il
prossimo video belle ragazze